hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreign again
usually I do videos on Thursdays cuz of
the Dead stream but there is a title
update going live on Thursday but it was
released and the patch notes and stuff
were released on Tuesday which is today
so I thought I'd go through though with
you guys we're gonna be talking about
everything there's some patch notes some
nerves and buffs to Raiders so that
title is not a lie I guarantee you that
a little some bug fixes and some arcade
improvements so sit down let's act like
this is a little bit of a book club I'll
leave the link to this in the
description down below if you guys want
to read that along with me will be a big
giant book club family will be going
through all this stuff so grab a coffee
sit down relax and let's get started
with this my Twitter and disk are to be
in the description down below if you
guys want to check that out let's get
started with this patch note so this is
title update 2.10 like I said this will
be releasing on June 6th also known as a
Thursday which is in a couple days
depending on when you're watching this
this may also be out but if you're
watching this the day of then you got a
couple more days they're most likely
gonna be talking about this on the dev
stream but I wanted to talk about this
now since this has some very interesting
stuff and I do believe this counts as
the midseason patch so this is what's
gonna be happening and usually with
these patches there's gonna be some
pretty drastic changes so let's see what
they got so first up is improvements
there's going to be a new out of stamina
logic the developer comment says went
out of stamina stamina will no further
be drained throughout any means
attacking getting parried getting hit
moves depleting stamina etc will now
have no effect other than pausing your
stamina drain if the move had this
property before so for example if you
were out of stamina against a Centurion
a Raider they will basically charge you
hit you punch you all that stuff and
you're gonna be taking out of stamina
and you're of course gonna be out of
stamina but if you're already out of
stamina you're going to be losing it and
go all the way back down to zero this
isn't the case anymore you're not going
to lose any stamina when you are out of
it you're going to be halted and stopped
at whatever that bar is it's gonna wait
a couple seconds or so and then go back
up and try to get you back to stamina
this was a because if you're trying to
play a little bit defensive since when
you're out of stamina you try to be a
lot more defensive and it basically just
made it worse and you had to parry you
had to get all your stamina back as
quick as you can but characters like
Centurion and Raider could you Rana
instantly regardless of what it was that
it's really glad that that was changed
and also on top of this moves that were
allowed to take 20 stamina from the
opponent visitin how the changes Raider
is going to be getting a stunning tap
buff his stunning tap will now
30 stamina damage so instead of 20lb 30
the follow up knee when knocked into a
wall now does 40 stamina damage for
Valkyrie her sidelight finishers are now
going to do 80 stamina damage which is
pretty big that's the one where she hits
you in the head with the shield so I
think that's pretty fair the knocking an
opponent into a wall during crashing
charge for warlord is not going to do 60
damage in terms of stamina and then
Raiders top heavy attack and now deals
50 stamina damage the second top heavy
in the chain now does 60 the top heavy
finisher does 80 stamina blind justice
does 15 as well as the light were passed
also does 15 stamina damage now I just
want to preface this that this is
stamina damage this is not actual damage
rate law burgers top every finisher
doesn't do 80 actual damage is just 82
your stamina so if you do get hit by
this you will be of course losing some
amount of health but majority of it is
gonna go to your stamina for actual
damage stuff first up we also have
Raider for the fighter section his
stunning tapping out is 15 damage it was
18 so it decreased by 3 so on top of
them adding more stamina damage they're
going to be decreasing the actual damage
of the stunning tab so I have no problem
with that
stunning tab indicator is now not shown
for the first 100 milliseconds to
prevent flicker so if any of you are
unaware the stunning tap is 500
milliseconds but it looks like it's 400
because the guard of the over where it's
coming flickers a little bit and then
goes up to the top that was a huge
problem we had back in the beginning of
the of the game for 4 on our back in
season 2 and through it flicker moves
especially orochi's don't attack so now
that 100 millisecond thing of the
flicker is going to be removed so it's
still going to be 500 it'll be displayed
as a 400 millisecond move because the
indicator won't be there but the timing
is still the same and it's to help other
players to get away from that flicker
which honestly I'm completely okay with
because that was a little bit of a pain
and they also removed the back dodged
any side dodge GB which is nice so with
radar if any of you are unaware Raider
had this ability to where he could side
dodge and that guard break or back
dodging guard break that is now gone and
as well with that move it allowed him to
protect him from dodging so if he was
out of stamina and dodging he could
counter guard break if someone tried to
guard break them now that is not the
case anymore since he can't side dodge
guard break back dodge guard break he so
Raider players have to be a little bit
aware when they're out of stamina and
try not to be dodging as much because
then they'll be caught with a GP
is gonna be a lot of technical numbers
but warlord has a lot of stuff with his
throw distance if you throw an opponent
from the front it was reduced by one
meter the left throw was reduced by 1.7
meters and the right throw is also the
same at 1.75 meters the back throw
distance has been reduced by 0.5 and he
crashing charged with it has been
reduced by 1 meter now if this didn't
make any sense I completely understand
but basically a quick sum of what that
means if Raider is not going to be
tossing people as far with his throw
distance meaning they won't be ledged
and it won't be wall spotted as often
it's still going to be a dangerous throw
of course but it's not going to be as
deadly since they reduced the range so
you won't be getting hit into walls or
ledges as much depending on how far you
are the same thing also happened to
shaman I'm just gonna be going through
hers but remember this is the exact same
reason for warlord her front throw has
now reduced to 0.5 meters left or was
0.75 meters right throw is 1 meter and
back throw is 1.5 meters and also do not
worry if you are a shaman player this
does not affect your follow-ups
regardless of where of how you throw
them and regardless of the distance you
still we will be able to connect with
her follow-ups or dashing heavies and
stuff like that so do not worry about
that part for arcade they added an extra
chance of getting battle outfits
ornaments and embossing for completing
the weekly arcade quest for ranked the
ranked penalties are now going to be
listed in the ranking update screen so
just the case anybody didn't know what
they were they're going to be there now
and for customization the emblems can be
displayed on more armor parts the
characters team has revised their rules
and regulations of the color swatches
we're allowing more neutral colors to be
used as attacker and defender color
swatches which is cool a lot of people
have just been asking to just say [ __ ]
it and just give us all one color
palette for regardless of its neutral
attack or defender just give them all of
it I don't think they want to do that of
course they want to make sure that
people understand what team they're on
so they're allowing more of the neutral
colors to be part of the attackers and
defenders to kind of that compromise on
top of that we have some more bug fixes
now that we're at this part I will be
talking about most of the majority of
these if hopefully all of them if
they're worth it but some of them are a
little bit you know just kind of there
and they're not too important so this is
where I like to link the thing in the
description like I said if you want to
look at every single bug fix for your
character and anything that happened to
be for a map that you play but for the
ones that mean you know kind of that are
a lot more important one of them is that
it reduced the occurrence of an issue
that caused some of the players to
notice that their revenge wasn't
building up in situations where it
should for example I've
experience this as well maybe some of
you guys have Journal one on two one on
three your revenge doesn't build up as
fast as it should allowing you to
basically just get absolutely destroyed
because you have no revenge to help you
with that that is hopefully going to be
fixed it won't be completely fixed but
it will be reduced hopefully by a lot so
let's see how that goes on June 6th a
few other bug fixes allowed the side D
flex to be performed a lot better they
used to be super hard but now they're
just a little bit better correcting the
timings and the side dodged movement and
stuff like that it's going to be a lot
easier to make those there was a bug fix
that also caused that players to take a
lot more damage when exiting a ladder
that's going to be taken away it's also
the same thing with the crop with the
ballistas that's actually legit the
latter one was a bit different but I do
know that when you're on a ballista you
actually can take more damage when
you're on that that for some odd reason
carried over to the ladder in certain
scenarios so now that's going to be gone
and it also fixed an issue that was
allowing a drop attack to be successful
even if the hero was killed during the
drop attack fix another issue with
Raiders Stampede charge did not be
completely interrupted by shamans
predator mercy fixed a bug with a pink a
visual effect from the heavy starters of
shougo key since it conflicted with the
uninterruptible stance visual effect it
also fixed an issue with shinobi being
able to cancel his second dodge into an
attack if a player q2 stands charged
right before the dodge and then besides
having some UI fixes in customization
for custom match in specific there's now
an adjustment you can now select the
phase in which you want to start the
match when playing breed from custom
match I'm assuming that's going to mean
you can start from the third phase right
up to the commander or from the
beginning or the second phase completely
understand that I know a lot of people
were trying to test out if he topiary
speak get to could kill the commander of
one shot and people were trying to test
that out but they'd have to go through
all the rounds of breach to do that be a
guys that's just about it let me know
what you guys think about the patch in
the comments below for a patch 2.10 the
title update on June 6th I know that one
of the more conflict thing ones and the
more of the controversial ones is going
to be the Raider buff to his stunning
tap stamina damage of course the
stunning tap is now decreased in damage
from 15 to 18 but the stamina damage is
even higher than it was before and that
was probably going to affect a lot of
players and seeing as stamina is very
key when fighting and trying to defeat
Raider and now you have even less of it
the more that he hits you with it and a
lot of people have been getting hit with
the stunning tap recently because of the
change to its move
and now that the flicker is gonna be
gone it might help a little bit but it's
still going to seem like a 400
millisecond move if people go based off
of reaction to the indicator and not
just the movement hey guys it's going to
be the end of the vid say hope you guys
did enjoy like I said this was a patch
going out on Thursday June 6th it's
probably going to be talked about in the
dead stream on June 6th but don't worry
I'm just gonna probably recap that and
Thursday's video as well for the people
that don't see this video but I just
want to give this out to you guys as
soon as I can because this is some very
important stuff and I wanted people to
know understand what is going to be
happening in the future in the next
couple days
and honestly I completely forgot to add
this part in the middle of the video but
I completely forgot that they didn't
even add the gladiator guard stance buff
so any gladiator players we're most
likely going to be getting it either in
a small patch during the season or in
season 11 which is pissing me off
already but I guess I'll just have to
wait even more than I already have
yeah lichte v if you do enjoy guys
subscribed for new I covered the
informational site a foreigner that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the petrodes and the leaks if
you want to be kept up today with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner and never miss under nothing
deaf we stay subscribe to the channel
but my two most recent videos are gonna
be popping up on screen if you guys do
want to check that out with that guys
hope you have a great yesterday thank
you for watching the video peace out and
I'll see you all on Thursday
[Music]
you
[Music]